the Joe Rogan experience but I got a
story that I don't want to tell because
in front of my girlfriend cuz it will
upset her because I will make my life a
bit harder and I don't want to tell it
on any tonight's shows anything so I'll
tell him I just did a zombie movie in
Australia which isn't anything to do
this story but I was in Australia and so
I'm in Australia my parents drive the
camera where we were on the weekend to
spend a day with me and fern I fancy my
parents in six months or something so
I'm spending time with my mum and dad
now back in the early 90s my father was
getting closer to retirement and then he
found a credit card because my mother
took care of the money found out that
she had run up $90,000 worth of bills
which meant my dad had to work an extra
sort of eight years past retirement to
pay these all off and she'd kept it all
secret okay so now my parents have got
to retirement they are in the house and
they just get a pension of like
Australian government gives each person
like $300 a week pension which is like
260 American right so my parents live
off that and then but my father takes
care of all the money he pays all the
bills and he bounced books because my
mum can't be trusted when it comes to
shopping and so I'm talking my parents
my mum goes all I want is my half of the
money here's half of the money and then
we'll see can have his half of the money
we'll split the bills and then I can do
what I want with my money but instead
I'm given an allowance because I'm not
responsible everybody I said mum you
can't take care of the money ma'am you
can't cuz you'll fuck it up you'll go
online you've you found internet
shopping now you'll fuck it up you'll
get rid of or credit cards you'll be
terrible and she goes oh I'm not the
problem with money anymore your father's
the one that spends all the make now
we're in a public bar by the way there's
many people sitting around us it's a
very public open area your father's the
one who spends all the money now and
then she points about angers tell him
tell him what you spend your money on
and I've already clicked what this won't
be and I've gone
oh no wait look I don't want to know I
don't want to know and then my brother
goes your father gets prostitutes right
and I've gone oh just shut up both of
you please four farms I God and she's
gone yep every Wednesday your father
before he goes to play lawn bowls goes
off and gets himself a prostitute and
then my dad went not every Wednesday
not every Wednesday may seem sounds like
at least three out of four Wednesday it
takes a week off every now and again
yeah like it cost him in Australia money
for a very cheap prostitute it's legal
in Australia in a brothel maybe a
hundred bucks for a pretty low end sort
of girl a rub-and-tug power so he went
to a place to get it done he didn't no
no it's not like he where you got to go
to a hotel and I type of stuff there's
just brothels and there they're very
legal they're very well signposted and
stuff it's not it's not such a big deal
in Australia it actually makes it a bit
safer if anything because the girls have
to get tasted have to bring their
results in all the time and they're
playing it definitely makes it safer
it's like everything else as soon as the
government says it can't be a legal when
it's something that people really enjoy
doing Louis doesn't work substantially
of course does oh shut up Jake it's like
laughing I don't begrudge my dad for
doing this I just don't want to hear
about my mother they're in their 70s my
mom is morbidly obese my dad's still
quite fit of course he wants to get his
end away sometimes
you